some people would love to talk to their
pet dog but there's something I learned
and that is animals have their own
language that we humans have yet to
decipher take a look at the porpoise I
had a chance to swim with the porpoise
for a Science Channel special and I was
quite curious about what we know about
the language of the porpoise basically
nothing we can take record their
language it has whistles it has clicks
but we don't know what they're saying
but there is a software program that can
tell that it's an intelligent language
if you take the English language we know
that the letter e is the most common
letter and you can rank these letters by
how often they appear that's how you
know that the English language is a
language of intelligent sentient beings
by using a computer program even if you
don't speak a word of English well you
can do the same thing with porpoises run
the language of the porpoise through a
computer program and bingo is
intelligent but we don't know what
they're saying so dogs yeah they may
have a very sophisticated language but
we have yet to decipher all the whining
barking noises they make except of
course the gross one they make late at
night so we have a long ways to go
before we can talk to our dogs